i'm really good we got both
here but in general right
i've seen it i've seen in your comments
i've i've studied your comments people
tend to think that or regard you as a
high-value woman and people have said
that right um i don't know if you agree
with disagree but people have said that
i think a high value woman's a virgin
i'm not a virgin fair enough fair enough
lease yourself away yeah but i think i
think they just gassed me up
but
so you say you're not a high volume but
would you would you be okay with that
genuinely
did i stutter
did i did i stutter
somehow i figure i will self-respect
that but fair enough
my point is is that the sort of women
that would say yes it's called we're on
a discount
i don't know
no i wouldn't i wouldn't like that but i
don't think if i if if i had kids i
wouldn't leave that's that's a bit
different though i think that would be
different if i'm young
it depends how you're like if i'm 30 and
i don't got kids yeah
i might have to stay like where's the
grass greener i'm 30 now like
but
i get what you're saying with you know
the whole 30 thing but
generally right now your age you
wouldn't
be okay i wouldn't prefer it now and so
i think that shows that already the pool
of women that would actually be okay
with with that sort of lifestyle right
it's not exactly the best pool of
women honestly
yeah
a lot of girls would be okay with it but
then just because it's a lot doesn't
mean they're good quantities and always
quality no you could argue that but
i don't know i i think there's more
girls that be okay with it that you
don't have to listen to like what girls
say watch what they do no i don't i
don't doubt that but what i'm saying is
generally yeah the whip surely you'd be
looking for if you're going to have a
woman in your life and take a seriously
surely be looking for like the
exceptional ones rather than the the
ones that will be okay with being one of
twenty two for one
not even a discount
surely you'd want the best of the best
or the best you can get rather than yeah
you know the ones that are okay being
one of twenty yeah because
there is no one or two
i mean personally i'm good i i'd rather
have one wife right
okay well we'll try this out for someone
else
[Laughter]
30 off at 27.
i'm 25 but i'm like going off early you
know
it's like an early sale only 26 this
year yeah i'm 26 in november it's coming
close man it's coming up
[Music]
no i mean i don't know i'm not a guy so
i'd imagine that i don't know politician
wives like they seem pretty high quality
woman a lot of them so
like melania trump i'm sorry i think
she's a high quality woman she gets
cheated on
like
like but is that lifestyle
can you prescribe that lifestyle to the
average person because
that's another problem i have with this
content you're saying this to the people
who will never reach that level yeah but
then they're still going to try to
implement it into their lives and it
won't go well for them and then no
wonder they'll be it's just further
propagating narrative that these women
are trash modern women are bad but then
you can't sustain that lifestyle you
don't have the finances or you're not
the sort of person that can sustain that
sort of lifestyle well i think they push
men to get that sort of lifestyle so
they can do that partially
that's simple
i don't understand why that's the thing
you should be pushing them towards i
think you should be pushing them to
become better they want money too and
muscles yeah but that's what i'm saying
i think you should push them to become
better and generally i i've seen in life
that as you get more muscles people tend
to like you more as you get more money
people tend to like you more however
rather than just
making that the goal right the women be
the goal why not just try to make men
just better in general
um
i would say that's what they do they
push men to be better overall not not
roller depends on the content creator
yeah but yeah i would say most of them
push men to be better overall and get
women in the process
but do you think that a man who is they
always say never chase women
they say that but then they contradict
themselves so if you if you're saying if
you're telling guys right that you
shouldn't marry you shouldn't marry or
settle down a woman until you've had at
least 40 bodies right don't you think
that someone tells you that there's only
one channel that prescribes that
but that's one of the biggest ones and
if you're telling if you're telling guys
that that's the thing you should be
doing surely that you're going to be
chasing
wow that's a lot of bodies
yeah well
i mean they can they can do that of
course they can't
but this is what i'm saying it somewhat
contradicts the message right well i
think i think it's more like to get
practice
with games you don't need 40 buddies for
practicing
some people some you know some shooters
do the extra mile after practice
they'll really be putting in jump shots
so like some people just want to go the
extra you know that's that's fine that's
fine maybe it could be 10 it could be
20. that's right i will say i think most
girls can feel it if a guy's experienced
with women and not in like a good way
it's sad it's sad because like before a
birth control happened like they
wouldn't have to yeah but like the
world's different now and it's sad but
it's just like is what it is
the world isn't like it used to be but
surely
you know if you have a platform where
you can influence people's decisions not
use specifically what i'm saying in
general if you have a platform where
because i've seen people ask them this
ask a lot of these regular people this
sort of question where you know you have
a platform where you can influence
people why wouldn't you use it to try to
do that right in terms of making it go
towards the other way so they tend to
always mention the fact that oh well
this is our biological imperative yeah
this is what we want to do and so
there's nobody trying to yeah to fight
it but surely i say build your own
platform and do it yourself that's what
i'm trying to do that's what i'm trying
to do before you criticize what other
people do with their platform some
people just want to be informational but
as informational and then there's
you're still prescribing stuff like you
can be information i mean i just okay
unless you give me specific people i
don't know who you're talking about
because you like you'll kind of ask me
like about the red pill in general but
there's a lot of variations between
the channels
okay so right now like if we're talking
about fresh and fit
they give advice they're an advice
channel and they feel like the best way
to get leverage over women is to screw
as many as possible and there's some
there's some evidence that supports it
because like
you know girls
girls bond through like orgasms so if
you get better at sex like you can get
more girls obsessed with you
like that's not fun but it's just how
girls bond yeah and you can even see
like reddit threads and like tick-tock
threads um like where girls talk about
how they miss the best sex of their life
and that sort of thing so
that's yeah that's fair but that's i i
wouldn't i wouldn't recommend that but i
can understand why they would you know
yeah no that's but that's fair we've
only got a couple minutes left so i just
want to ask you one last question one
question
would you rather
start an only funds
okay where you do whatever people
request oh god or
be one of angitate's women
i think one of andrew dates women before
i [ __ ] did it only fans no
i mean at least he's like he's rich i
could be like if i'm gonna cry i'm gonna
cry my mansion then get the
guy like i would much rather do that
than put my body on the internet for
everyone else to see i mean you'd be one
of those kind girls though
i would i'd be one i don't think so i
swear these guys are usually come girls
not anymore that was back like when he
started
he does casinos now oh yeah that's true
yeah i'm pretty sure he's kind of
business though he might but i don't
think his main chick is on cams
he has a girlfriend he has a uh his
girlfriend in like six years he's got
worms yeah yeah
like i heard i heard someone say that
before they would they won't be serious
like no yeah i would pick as long as if
i'm on the can